i i i want to watch this movie i changed
my mind make this one
charlie dave versus the rescuers i'm
into it
the rescuer
[Laughter]
nina what's the worst movie that they
could remake as a live action film
thanks for asking brian um i
i had a little trouble settling on one
because so many of the things i thought
were terrible ideas have either already
happened or
are in production so that's unsettling
um and i should also say that i have
seen several
of the live-action remakes and i'm
across the board not a fan
um so that's where i'm coming from as an
audience member
i understand and i thought a lot about
my least favorite
which was the beauty and the beast
adaptation which had a number of
problems
including like girl boss belle and the
idea that every single
thing in the castle was alive which well
let's so girl boss belle you mean
like the the pandering way in which they
were like she's in the science and then
it just doesn't come into play at all
and also like there's a whole subplot
where she gets in trouble for teaching a
young girl to read even though
young like children literacy was very
championed in france at the time when
this film is set so it doesn't
work yeah okay but so i was thinking
about some of the more unsettling
parts of that film and i think anyone
who has seen that movie knows how
creepy the beast looks for the entire
movie until he turns back into
downton abbey stan stevens and in that
vein i was thinking about how horrifying
it would be if lilo and stitch were
adapted into a live action remake and we
had to look at a fully realized cgi
stitch
oh no i thought they are making that one
i checked i could be wrong okay um you
checked i didn't
so you would know better i don't i don't
want to see that in the immortal words
of lisa cooter in the comeback i don't
want to see that
you don't want to see a cute little cgi
think about
well but they don't make anything cute
in these live-action remakes all the
lions and the lion king were
horrifying too and that's a real animal
that exists
not an alien that's kind of like
adorably creepy but weird objectively
incarcerated specifically not yeah i
don't want to see like
andy circus in a motion capture suit in
lilo and stitch i do
not need that kind of energy in my life
actually you know what
maybe i would only like if it were andy
circus but it probably won't be so i
still don't want to see it
i would love it if it was andy circus
but they never animated over it if it
was just this middle-aged man in a unit
that a child is raising like the movie
walk like a man from the 80s starring
howie
i would watch that but you know that's
not you know that's not what's
that's not what would come of this it
would just be like an
uncanny valley nightmare causing
instrument of chaos brian you had
a rebuttal yes i do have a rebuttal i
don't think you're wrong
because they would just do a cgi
situation but what if
look to your to to behind you to your
i don't know which direction it is
because zoom is is weird but but yeah
that one
who who do you see behind you baby you
see the love of my life baby yoda
practical effect what if they made a
stitch that's a practical effect
that's adorable that's animatronic
that's
you know got a person's hand in it doing
this okay counterpoint
yeah baby yoda just kind of sits around
and just makes cooing baby noises
stitches
very active presence he doesn't do a lot
of action scenes he doesn't do a lot of
movement and that's kind of why he's
soaked he
he waddles and he goes like this and he
makes cute baby noises and
cookies yeah yeah he he eats soup
yeah you're right just like really
really quick point of interest just
because i can already hear people
smashing their keyboards to death uh
i do think it's important to point out
that baby yoda does have a real name
and that it's steven merchant yoda
grogu stephen merchant yoda he's named
for his godfather
read the lore yeah i remember i remember
when when watched the cartoons
when the name was revealed uh before i
had a
chance to see it all i saw on twitter i
was like why is everyone posting about
goku what
what is huh and then i watched it i was
like oh
i'm not falling for this for this trick
his name's baby yoda as he
is known in my heart i want him to be
named yo diddly
like yoda and then the lady yoda was
yattle
from the prequels the logical progress
everybody's deadly favorite character
from the prequels old seattle
yeah yeah fun super popular
started as a teenage yoda puppet and
then they were like nah that's stupid
just
just make it a girl and so then they
made it
a different character anyway we've got
off topic she only showed up in one
movie though right
i'm pretty sure only one movie i think
there might be some comic book
stuff about her but very little as far
as i know
i'm not up on my gatling baby yoda
rebuttals aside my pick is lilo and
stitch
that's a really good pick because lilo
and stitch is a great movie
and that's the other thing yeah just my
second choice was emperor's new groove
because i wouldn't want them to ruin it
right because that movie is good
legitimate and i i feel the same way
about lilo and stitch i like that movie
and i don't want them to
mess it up because that was my yeah my
pick was that person
yeah which i will briefly discuss now um
that was my pick it's one of my favorite
disney movies because i think it's
super duper funny it's so funny and one
of the reasons that it works so well is
because it's a cartoon that knows it's a
cartoon
right it really works with the like form
yeah exactly it's very much
it's the most warner brothers-y disney
movie
you know like it's got like that spirit
of like the old bugs bunny daffy duck
cartoons of
just like exactly very chuck jones it's
and it's just like
it's it's i want to say it's goofy but
that's bringing a whole different
character into this
um but there's just all this great stuff
in there that wouldn't
be translated into a live-action remake
it would just be kind of
meh it would be kind of lame um so yeah
i would be less
interested in seeing that i think that
would be a huge bummer anyway that was
one of my picks and i just wanted to
mention it i have another one as a
backup just in case but anyway
no and i wasn't going to talk about
emperor's new groove uh but you did
anyway
you brought it up and i know um it was
it's called a segway brian
um no it's okay i know it's but i agree
with you completely that movie is so
much fun and
i i don't i don't want it to to be
completely molded into something
creepy and weird i think the main thing
here on both of these picks is that
it's the main problem with a lot of
these live-action remakes which is that
these stories these films work really
well because they're
animated films and animation as a medium
has a lot of strengths that live action
doesn't so when you translate it to live
action you lose a lot and you introduce
all these strange things like
uncanny valley objects and beasts
mansion excuse me creepy beast face
creepy stitch from lilo and stitch that
we're hoping we don't get
and the expressiveness of characters in
lilo and stitch and emperor's new groove
is really important to both of these
movies like the facial reactions and i
know that that
i watched a couple clips of the lion
king because i wanted to
keep sleeping at night but um i didn't
sit down for the entire film but i saw
that the main criticism was that
the there was no emotion at all once
don't move because lions faces
right and so like imagine how bad
emperor's new groove would be if they
couldn't do any funny facial reactions
yeah photorealistic llama yeah with
peanut butter on its lips
there's a reason that the live action
the remake of uh mr
ed didn't go anywhere right except
straight to our hearts
you can find it on youtube it's
terrifying the remake of mr ed
it's real bad anyway tom wait i'm sorry
what era was the remake of mr head
i want to say it's late 90s yeah i think
there's
there's an unaired pilot on youtube that
i caught a few minutes of that was just
really really bad we were a pachinski
family so i
never really had the opportunity tom
what's your pick
i had a hard time with this one because
my my gut reaction
just in terms of like and keeping in
mind the lion king which and i love john
favreau but like
nothing about that movie really worked
right
somehow he managed to be like the only
filmmaker in history to get a small
performance out of billy eichner
[Laughter]
and arguably beyonce yeah yeah
and like and like you you were talking
about the characterization and all the
stuff
that you get to do with with uh you know
fantasy animation i guess
all of the musical numbers lost all of
that kind of
sense of wonder that you remember seeing
watching the classics right
and instead it becomes two hours of like
animals walking
in a straight line and reciting lyrics
to songs that you've heard before
so my my initial reaction was uh
fantasia
and then i remembered that they did
already that they made
sure there's back in the uh back during
the
kind of pirates of the caribbean era of
uh let's take
anything that we own the name to and see
if we can turn it into a pg-13 right
the haunted mansion why wouldn't this
yeah
so that was my initial reaction what i
what i landed on was uh
was the rescuers um that's a good thing
good pick i loved that movie
i watched it the only version of it that
i would want to see
is if they made it kind of in the same
way that they made the original rescuers
which was
they had all these terrible production
issues where like the
i think the movie got shelved for like a
decade and then a new team of animators
came on
and finished it so like if you watch the
movie the first half looks entirely
different from the second half like the
the main character's eyes change
shape and right basically turn into
these completely different
creatures and if we wanted to do it like
that i would be 100 on board
i was gonna say like would charlie
kaufman be involved like that sounds
like
i don't really see a way that we could
keep him out so if you did a rescuer's
remake he's wiring starring charlie day
[Music]
is he playing one of the mice or is he
he's all the parts
is he using his rat stick on yeah he's
all about i
i i want to watch this movie i changed
my mind make this one
charlie dave versus the rescuer i'm into
it
the rescuer
[Laughter]
the only other one that i had i guess i
had two just in the chamber
and they're obvious ones hunchback of
notre dame how would that work
yeah how do you make a kids movie out of
the hunchback of notre dame without
animating it and the answer is you don't
[Music]
well they made several live-action
movies in the past of hunchback of notre
dame and they were all really unsettling
right and if disney made it if disney
made a remake of their
remake yeah you know because they
rewrote the whole story
at the ending so it's less horrific yeah
you know that would be really
terrible and then the other one
obviously is pocahontas
so i'm just going to pocahontas right i
mean
again how do you disney like the only
reason why the disney version that
exists
even works at all if it arguably works
at all
is because it's animated as soon as you
remove the layer of unreality and
put actual actors doing these things in
there
it just it falls apart yeah probably a
better idea to just leave that one alone
does it feel like the pocahontas cartoon
was like
a series of hundreds and hundreds of
people too afraid to say this is a bad
idea to their boss
yeah i don't know i was reading about
the production act because that one that
sprang to mind and
uh it sounds like the guy who was
running disney animation at the time
they had a thanksgiving dinner
and came up with this idea and that was
the entire origin story for this movie
and
uh i just i can't imagine i can't
imagine the production process on this
because
it was years you know it took years to
make this right i'm just thinking of all
of these
kind of underlings in dark corners of
the disney animation studio like huddled
around each other going this is this is
bad
right like we're not going to work again
yeah at no point in those many years did
anyone just go
uh didn't wasn't pocahontas a young
teenager who was kidnapped from
her home and brought to england and died
of a preventable disease because she
yeah because she was taken like a couple
years later yeah at no point did anyone
just bring that
actual solid fact up
they probably went over that stuff in
the direct-to-video sequel
right i didn't watch it but i can only
assume that they address these as a girl
who watched a lot of pocahontas they did
not cover any of that in the
direct-to-video sequel
that's a shame yeah oh wow that didn't
come up somehow
weird next time thanks for watching
please hit
like and subscribe so you don't miss a
single video